[Applause]
it's always marvelous on your mothers in
the audience
um
did anybody notice that both the
speakers for the proposition got their
defense in early suggested that you
wouldn't be open-minded on this that you
probably had already made up your mind I
wonder what it is ladies and gentlemen
that makes them not be confident in the
case they want to make this evening and
I think it's something rather simple
it's that I'm not sure we've actually
had the brexit that they promised us I
think we might have had brexit in name
only so let's look at the actual
evidence of this and and I talk about
brexit since it actually happened not
2016 but actually when we did leave the
single market and join this wonderful
Free Trade Agreement because all the
evidence suggests that we have all the
economic and social hit of leaving the
European Union but none of the freedoms
and benefits that were promised no one
least of all Daniel I know can be happy
with that
Daniel I think of rather affectionately
as the Kaiser Soze of brexit you didn't
see him coming but we've all seen the
consequences to be fair to Daniel he
wasn't one of those people promising us
that net migration would be under a
hundred thousand a year that was Michael
Gove it is now 239
000 a year he didn't drive a bus with
350 million for the NHS written on the
back of it too far the NHS has had more
money that's down to the pandemic not
brexit and he didn't say we would take
back control of our fish but the new
research showing this year that
significant EU access to the waters
around the UK remain indeed to those in
six to seven twelve nautical miles that
we were promised would be hours and
hours alone and in fact the evidence
shows us that since we left the European
Union the brexit trade deal means that
exporting fish and seafood costs more
and takes longer so the fish is less
fresh and the customers have been lost
so perhaps have more chips and less fish
with your national dish thanks to brexit
Daniel did say we could do better than
being part of this Regional Association
he calls it largest trading block in the
world to everybody else but no matter
geography wasn't important to him the UK
has yet to implement though since we
left the European Union a single brand
new trade deal that it couldn't have had
under the existing terms of the European
Union Even in our relationship with
Japan indeed the only point of
contention about the new trade deal with
Japan is whether we are worse off than
we would have been if we'd stayed in the
European Union
Daniel didn't argue that we would need
to leave the single Market but has now
argued that we should never have left
but it would be mad to go back it's a
bit like being locked out of your house
but then saying it's Madness to go and
see a locksmith and get some keys cut so
that you can actually get back in So
this this brexit that nobody will take
responsibility for what has it given us
well as Ian Martin that well-known
Ramona has told us exports for the EU
I'm sorry to report Robin are down
almost 12 percent that's not an
insubstantial figure indeed the UK in a
changing Europe's research and
independent body shows that brexit has a
25 fall in Imports why does that matter
because the Fallen Imports isn't just
about whether you can eat french Brie or
have
um a German sausage it's actually about
the money and the impact that you have
on our production lines two-thirds of
international trade is products that we
use as inputs in our chains of
production and supply chain what does
that mean in practice for all of us it
means it's much harder for our
businesses to make do little wonder that
EU UK trade relationships are down 33
and it is mainly small businesses we
might be a nation of shopkeepers but
many are shutting up shop as a result of
brexit indeed it has affected the cost
of living the biggest crisis that we now
face post pandemic the increase in those
trade barriers has led to a six percent
increase in food prices again not my
words the UK and a changing Europe
independent research inflation in food
products that Britain tends to import
from the European Union like fresh pork
tomatoes and jams was much more
pronounced than that tuna or exotic
fruit so basically ladies and gentlemen
you're left with a Hawaiian pizza and
not much else
because you cannot eat red tape but
you've got an awful lot more of it as a
result of brexit and that is a hit not
just for trade but also for our tax take
because the obr again an independent
body I'm sorry it's disappoint you
Robert shows that economic growth is
down four percent as a result of these
Trends and every one percent of loss of
growth is a nine billion pound loss of
revenue for the NHS for social care for
our policing but what about those
regulatory freedoms we were promised
surely surely those are those Sunny
uplit lands well the reality shows us
that since we've left the European Union
very little has changed and it's not
hard to see why the Divergence tracker
shows us that for all those freedoms
that were hard fought by people like
Daniel and Robert there are only 27
cases of actual Divergence from those
thousands of restrictive rules that the
EU brought us in let's have a look at
what some of those might be those
benefits that you are voting for if you
vote Yes tonight well they do include
trophy hunting but not forgot and fur
because of course nothing is too good
for the workers it is about compensation
on flights the government is using
Divergence to make sure that you don't
get as much compensation if your flight
is delayed if you are sat at Gatwick in
the coming weeks do think about that one
as a benefit of brexit also
non-recognition of blue badges for
disabled people again a point of
Divergence that the government has yet
to do anything about for those those 2.3
million of people for whom a blue badge
is a critical way of moving around the
country
as again UK and changing Europe point
out the benefits of brexit document the
government produced all 105 Pages was
not short of ideas but many of those
ideas were things that you could have
done in the European Union anyway and
most are recycled and possibly asking
readers of the Sun as Jacob reesemork
has now done to come up with ideas isn't
the best use of those few civil servants
that have actually come into the
office's time because the truth is any
radical Divergence is unlikely to be
possible because what it does to
business is ask them to choose it ask
them to choose where they would only
trade in the UK or what they would only
trade with Europe or would they want to
run two separate Regulatory regimes and
with an audience nearby of 600 million
customers it's not hard to see why
business is calling for the government
not to be radical and indeed there are
some regulations you probably do want to
keep for good reason for example right
now the government is having to
reconfigure our Airline safety
regulations the ones that we've had from
Europe that meant that planes were
flying to AP could be be equally safe
everywhere we're having to redo we
haven't in the two minutes I've got left
you've got time to talk about services
or employment rights but when people
talk about European red type that's
often what they mean the fact that you
can have an employment contract at all
that comes from Europe that equal pay is
underpinned by European law and we know
from the beecroft report where this
government is intending to go on those
things and indeed Libertarians such as
Daniel and Robert are often fond of
telling us about the dangers of these
overbearing States but when the state
itself is taking away your rights who is
it who's left to look after you and one
of the challenges here is that the EU
was giving you many more protections
than you might have realized including
on decent consumer rights whether you
could indeed just buy one charger for
your phone I don't know about you but
I'd rather carry around one cable than
many again something that this
government has decided not to pick up we
haven't even talked about the shame that
is what is happening in Northern Ireland
as a result of playing fast and loose
with the Good Friday agreement
but if we got bryno has the EU changed
might be your question well surely we've
achieved that we've given them the short
sharp shock of walking out well not
really actually the EU has worked
together in Ukraine and we have been
outside the room looking in the EU again
has started to work together on refugees
yet we are outside the room looking in
and deciding to deport people to Rwanda
what have we got out of Europe then well
fewer politicians we don't have MEPS
like Daniel was we've got those blue
passports and the crown stamp on your
pint glass and some people have made an
awful lot of money out of it uh Crispin
O'Day and hedge fund manner who lately
contributed 650 000 pounds to the pro
leave campaign made 220 million pounds
betting as the pound collapsed post
Europe and of course it is given work
for politicians like myself when you've
got 1500 pieces of legislation to
rewrite we can do that rather than deal
with the cost living crisis or climate
change or the social care crisis so the
answer is you must vote that we were
wrong to do brexit but also we now need
to fix it that's not about rejoining
that's not on the table and it's not
something I'm advocating but it is about
accepting responsibility and your vote
tonight for the point that Dominic and I
make is to make people like Daniel and
Robert take responsibility because
Daniel you quoted the Henry the V speech
for in the fifth speech rather when the
campaign run the Band of Brothers who
fought for our freedom
um not least because that speech talks
about those who were not there should
hold their manhoods cheap when they
weren't fighting with you and I'll leave
you ladies and gentlemen think about
what manners they're talking about
because frankly the brexite has got this
country by the short and curlies but as
more Queen Margaret in Henry VI taught
us wise men nurse it and wear their loss
but cheerily seek how to redress their
harms so by voting with myself and
Dominic tonight you are sending a
message to Robert and to Daniel to be a
little less of a hooray Henry a much
more like Maggie thank you
thank you
[Applause]